hi i'm krista and i'm evan hey i'm
marissa and i'm bella welcome to the all
free clear mega packs challenge we put
together an obstacle course with a
series of challenges designed around
life's messiest moments once you
complete all of the challenges mom will
toss one all free clear mega packs into
the washer followed by your messy
clothes you only need one all-free clear
mega packs to tackle small medium and
large loads since it has two times the
stain lifting ingredients compared to a
regular mighty packs making it tough on
stains plus it's gentle for sensitive
skin which allows you to get back to the
things you love the most spending time
with family for your first challenge you
will need to dig through this pile of
messy clothes
to find the key that key will allow you
to enter the all free clear mega packs
course now to begin are you ready to
embrace the mess i'm ready to embrace
the mess
[Music]
do you see it no i found it
i got
[Music]
okay i got the scooper now go to the
right
okay is that good
more
squeeze it
more
go forward yes i'm plugging it hurry
hurry spray everywhere spray it
everywhere everyone hurry
up
cereal
right next is scooper get the cereal
hurry to your left
marshmallow
grab it grab it grab it put it over here
put it everywhere go go
you got it
am i getting in the bowl yes all right
is our sunday look delicious yes yes
all right all right we gotta go we gotta
go
here comes the airplane
[Music]
red blue
white
here we go okay
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh my gosh
here help me with this one okay got it
grab the water grab the water
grow
okay
let's go hurry
we're good we're good let's go
here we go
done
done done
super messy best time what did you like
the best i liked the ice cream i liked
the drums drums the drums got us the
most messy for sure i love using all
free clear mega packs because they
conquer any size load and it's good for
sensitive skin
[Music]